in the 30 years since it hit theaters
virtually every superhero movie has been
influenced by what was first
accomplished in Batman 89 it's in fact
has been so massive that in a world
where it set the standards you might not
have even noticed how much of an effect
it had for those of you who don't
remember what it was like back in the
days leading up to June 23rd 1989 it
cannot be stressed enough that Batman
was everywhere that summer even in a
year crowded with massively successful
franchise movies like Indiana Jones and
the Last Crusade Ghostbusters 2 Back to
the Future 2 and the beginning of the
Disney Renaissance with the Little
Mermaid The Dark Knight was pop
culture's most inescapable character of
course movie marketing had existed for
as long as movies had but the Batman
marketing was on a whole different level
there were countless tions from toys to
breakfast cereals to a concept album by
Prince all of which arrived with some of
the strongest branding ever rather than
putting the spotlight on director Tim
Burton stars Michael Keaton and Jack
Nicholson or even the character of
Batman himself the marketing was
overwhelmingly focused on the iconic
image of Batman's emblem it started with
the first poster which was just the
emblem and a release date and continued
across countless t-shirts hats action
figures and pretty much everything else
in the meantime even the opening
sequence of the movie itself was just an
extreme close-up of that logo underneath
the credits by reducing the entire idea
of Batman down to that symbol using the
branding that had already been refined
over the past 50 years of comics and pop
culture Warner Brothers seared that
image into moviegoers minds and sold an
estimated five hundred million dollars
in merchandise alone adjusting for
inflation that's over 1 billion dollars
today all before we even get to the box
office take for the movie itself
I'm giving away free money for a movie
about a character famously known for
being super competent at crime-fighting
and having a plan for every
eventualities one of the weirdest
moments of Batman 89 comes right at the
beginning the very first thing we see
Batman do after he glides silently onto
a rooftop to confront two criminals who
have just committed a mugging is get
shot and fall down
seriously this is our introduction to
the Dark Knight finally returning to the
big screen for the first time in 23
years to be fair the crucial element
here is that after being shot Batman
gets back up it also showcases one of
the movie's changes to Batman his
costume isn't just a costume
it's bulletproof body armor wait a
minute what is that some kind of body
armor he's human after all before the
movie Batman's costume had usually been
depicted as being well a costume meant
to frighten criminals more than to
protect the person wearing it the
filmmakers apparently assumed that an
audience could accept rocket cars and
killer clowns but believing that someone
could fight crime without ever taking a
bullet to the chest was a little tough
to believe that sparked a trend in
superhero movies towards going to great
lengths to give a functional
justification for why the superheroes
were wearing those costumes it's easy to
draw a direct line from Batman's body
armor to the way the x-men talked about
their leather suits in the year 2000
actually go up side
what would you prefer yellow spandex and
all the way through the conversation in
2017 Justice League about how the
Flash's costume was made from Space
Shuttle parts if there's one thing
superhero movies love its an origin
story and Batman 89 is no exception
in fact it doesn't just stop with one
origin it gives us two not only are we
treated to the first of many times that
will see the Wayne family's ill-fated
trip down Crime Alley on the big screen
but most of the plot revolves around
another fateful story about who a
character is and how they came to be the
Joker terrorizes wait'll they get a load
of me unlike the comics where his
identity has always been shrouded in
mystery to the point of having
conflicting origins the movie gave us
the straightforward story of Jack Napier
who's merely unforgivable pun named and
lucky deck of cards led him to take the
identity of the Joker it seems like an
odd choice if only because there's no
real change to the character after he
takes his ill-fated acid bath he's
already a killer with a thing for
playing cards and a Wardrobe full of
purple suits his emergence as the Joker
just makes his crimes a little more
artistic gentlemen let's broaden our
minds
Batman 89s most crucial plot change was
making Jack Napier the crook who shot
Batman's parents that's never been a
part of the comics where the Wayne's
were shot by a mugger named Joe Chill as
we would eventually see in Batman Begins
the intent here was to give Batman a
personal connection to his archenemy
that would go beyond just criminal
versus crime fighter which brought the
super heroics story more in line with a
traditional action movie you killed my
parents
[Music]
are you talking about that set the tone
for virtually every superhero movie that
came after with personal connections
built into heroes and villains even when
they never existed in the comics an Iron
Man for instance Obadiah Stane wasn't
just the rival businessman that readers
knew from the comics he was a father
figure for Tony Stark who betrayed him
along the same lines the Eric kill
monger seen in the Black Panther movie
has a familial tied to T'Challa that his
comic book counterpart never did hey
aunty
that's not limited to superheroes either
this idea had an effect on the Joker
while Heath Ledger's performance in The
Dark Knight retained the characters
mysterious often conflicting origins the
upcoming Joker solo film is doing the
exact opposite it's even set to include
both Thomas and Bruce Wayne as
characters giving Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker the same sort of personal
connection to Batman that we saw in 1989
in the comics Batman has traditionally
been depicted as a character who doesn't
kill his enemies if only because it's
pretty tough for the Riddler to show up
again for his next story if Batman kicks
his head off in this one in the movie
however he racks up a body count that
doesn't just rival the Joker's it goes
well beyond it he shoots at his
opponents with vehicle-mounted machine
guns blows up a Factory full of goons
with Batmobile bombs tosses a dude to
his death from a bell tower and in the
end was a pretty direct hand in killing
the Joker his revenge for the Joker
murdering his parents that idea of
treating superhero stories like action
movies where the ending always comes
with the death of the bad guy didn't
necessarily start with Batman
9 years earlier Superman - ended with a
Man of Steel tossing the Phantom Zone
criminals down a bottomless pit in the
fortress of solitude still Batman
codified it setting up a pattern of
supervillains dying at the end of movies
often at the hands of the good guys that
wouldn't really be subverted until
spider-man homecoming where the villain
whose life gets spared at the end is
played by Michael Keaton when you think
of Gotham City the image that comes to
mind is a sprawling smoke-filled urban
nightmare it's a place with deep shadows
and gargoyles leering down from
every building we're clean Art Deco
designs are shoved right up against
buildings that might as well be modern
gothic castles it's a city that seems
built for a character like Batman and
that's an idea that pretty much starts
with this movie Gotham City has of
course always had its share of character
but it was mostly meant to be relatively
realistic as long time Batman writer and
editor Denny O'Neil put it Gotham was
Manhattan below 14th Street at 11
minutes past midnight on the coldest
night in November all of that changed
with the film Tim Burton's greatest
strength has always been his distinctive
visuals and he and production designer
Anton Furst put that on display in
Batman 89 they recreated Gotham as an
environment that was less like the New
York you could actually visit and more
like as Burton memorably described it a
city where he'll burst through the
pavement and grew the aesthetic stuck to
first designs were quickly incorporated
into the comics Canon in 1990 and Gotham
has retained that distinctly hellish
character ever since in 1978 Superman
the movie brought the Man of Steel to
our world
in 1989 Burton and first took us to
Batman city instead in a lot of ways
Batman 89 was far more inspired by the
60s TV show than the comics of the 80s
with its brightly colored knockout gas
Dutch angles and over-the-top villains
these are all the elements that harken
back to Adam West's tenure as the Caped
Crusader which makes a lot of sense as
much of the late 80s brought in
groundbreaking comics like The Dark
Knight Returns and Batman year one
decades of syndication had cemented the
show as the most prominent version of
the character in the larger pop culture
Burton did however draw influence from
further back in Batman's history in an
effort to evoke the character's roots
the style of the movie is largely
inspired by the fashions and aesthetics
of the 1940s it's clearly set in the
modern day there are computers modern
cars and you know prince but characters
like Jack Napier and Alex Knox we're
distinctly 40 style suits complete with
hats even Harvey Dent's campaign for
District Attorney as a visual reference
to Citizen Kane
the overall effect is that the movies
visuals are a very interesting blend of
Batman's past and present but in
retrospect it also serves as a sort of
proof of concept for the superhero movie
is a period piece it would take years
for this to really pay off but it's hard
to imagine a world where we go to movies
like Captain America the First Avenger
or x-men first class without Batman
paving the way for superheroes with a
retro aesthetic imagine that you're the
head of a movie studio in July of 1989
Batman is everywhere and you've watched
while it took ten days to become the
fastest movie to ever rack up 100
million dollars at the box office you
want another piece of that massive
success obviously the best thing to do
here is to make more superhero movies
and capitalize on the characters that
the public already loves right you who
am i number one guy wrong if you're
making movies in 1989 you apparently
look at the two highest-grossing movies
of the year Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade and Batman and decide that
moviegoers are just into movies about
stuff that was popular in the 30s and
40s the years after Batman's Titanic
success saw a sudden flood of movies
that attempted to capitalize on what
Studios clearly hoped was a trend
Dick Tracy in 1990 the shadow in 1994
and the Phantom in 1996 were all
revivals of characters who had been
hugely popular five decades earlier that
leaned into their pulpy aesthetics The
Rocketeer in 1991 and the mask in 1994
were both based on newer comics that had
been created in the 80s but that were
brought to the screen with the same kind
of retro 40s visuals it even extended to
TV where Darkwing Duck secret-identity
Drake Mallard hit airwaves in 1991 as a
full-on parody of the shadow secret
identity Kent
Allard and a character with whom its
target audience had zero familiarity
unfortunately for the studio executives
who really wanted audiences to love the
phantom like they did when they were
eight this was a false start of a trend
to jump on while there were some good
movies in that throwback crop none were
as memorable beloved or even remotely as
successful as Batman it turned out that
the public was far less interested in
characters who hit the
pop-cultural peak 50 years ago than they
were in actual superhero stories and it
would take another decade or two from
movie studios to come around to that one
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]